[Music]
I've been
thinking I can't run this club
forever I built this for
nothing this is my
[Music]
family you and me
kid from the
beginning yes
please
I was a golden age bike rider I never
felt so out of place in all my
life that's when I saw him for the first
time and took my breath away I'm
[Music]
Benny 5 weeks later I married
him I thought I could change him you
know not to be different but to be I
don't know like he's wild hey told you
to take that jacket off
you'd have to kill me to get this jacket
off oh
yeah what about the
bar bur it
down the club got real big real fast
they started running drugs gambling
prostitution is that what this club is
now I want you to quit riding don't ask
that
Benny I need you
you can't hand him if he wants to ride a
bike you're right B
yeah
[Music]
yeah hey you know
just just think it over you
know
ladies and gentlemen of the
jury how y'all doing for all of y'all
that don't know who I am my name is
Willie Gary willly Gary wi G William
Gary never heard of him what's so
special about this guy
anyway litigation is war it's a battle
bam and I'm not talking about no
[__] either I'm talking about some
Jean clae vanam ass kicking [__] truth
is I may have gotten myself into a lot
of trouble I've been your lawyer 30
years we can find a way out of it you've
never sued anybody it before in your
whole life tried to bully me out of
business and I don't think I should be
expected to stand for white Mr Gary
hasn't lost a case in over 12 years you
suggesting I hire this guy as one of my
lawyers y'all come on in pleasure to
meet you Mr Gary let me introduce you to
my call R how do you feel about working
with black folk I suppose I am a little
Prejudice did you meet my team I'm Chris
CH dougas chlen he's suing us he's suing
us we are a half a billion dollar
Corporation so how much money y'all
trying to get 8 million that ain't
enough money $100
million who is this clown he's hired as
a
lawyer you're fighter man what made you
want to do it cuz he tried to mess with
the one thing that means the most to me
in life being able to leave something
behind for my
grandchildren let's play some
music my name is main DS graduated top
of her class from Harvard Law School
they had a nickname for her around the
office the S I wouldn't get too used to
me being kind to you Mr Gary once we
begin that
trial I going destroy
you we don't have a snowballs chance in
hell winning this case just just trust
me okay I I I may have found something
what does it feel like to be some small
time nobody on the verge of
bankruptcy what if I don't win and I let
all these people down you have been
trying to turn this into your own one
ring circus I got my damn life on the
line I know that
Jerry did it ever bother you the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy you sit your ass
down
your hey hey hey wait wait what's we
split the po can't split the PO man come
on it gets pretty lonely out
here I need to regain the memories that
the creek took for me AE
Carol you are Carol daners the most
powerful person I knew way before you
could shoot fire from your fists I get
in trouble for that I can see that about
you but what happens
when
I'm finally set
[Music]
free I'll be back before you know it
lieutenant
trle and you
left mom passed away and I got flipped
back they rounded us to investigate
Earthbound anomalies Monica
no
how you feeling like
myself now I can manipulate wavelengths
of the electromagnetic spectrum I'm very
happy for you where's our daughter yes
where is Kamala who's Kamala oh my God
oh my God oh my
God
hi how do you have this my grandma sent
it to me in the mail have you ever
wanted something so
bad and it actually
happened but it's not as great as you
imagined it you going to save the
world then you're going to save the
world well now don't you tell
me what is happening we switch places
whenever we use our
powers higher further
faster
[Music]
together
I have a job for you piece of cake
really give your
head a security
gig
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
them
yet met
who
foxy Bonnie Chica
Freddy back in
the80s some kids went missing what is
this it's why the place shut
down the police searched Freddy's hey
they never found the
kid what the
[Music]
heck
ghost
children possessing giant
robots tell me how to stop
them you don't it's too
late he's
[Music]
coming
don't be
scared we've met
before are you looking for Reagan are
you looking for
aun RS in
[Music]
hell
get what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it
is we're born in this world with Hope
and
Dreams and a desire to be happy
Dad something's going on with my bar
help help it's happening to my daughter
too the devil has one wish Wherever
those girls went they brought something
back with
them to make us lose faith I believe you
can help get our daughters back to kill
it in us and the devil never gives
up she knows who I
am where's the other
girl he is waiting
him what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession come on baby come back to us
okay if you don't make it I don't make
it mama what is it baby I can't can't
youy I'm right here I don't want to go
to
hell God play that trick on
you they're two heartbeat is it working
leing in
syn be strong
strong what did you
do one girl lives one girl dies you get
[Music]
[Applause]
choose the next marvelous advancement in
robot is artificial intelligence
intelligence we should never have let AI
out of the box execute her or we go
extinct we're not killing the kid what
do they call you what's your name my
name is Alfie you're my friend who side
you want
man they're coming to get me she
Bel W what do you want sweetie for
robots to be free
we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice
cream the future's never looked
better the future's never looked
better the Creator R PG-13 old M theater
September 29th get tickets
[Music]
now yes hi hi I have some bad news we
lost your mom what sorry that was
terrible phrasing I meant we don't know
where she
is oh I think your sister's here Annie
It's finally happened oh my God it's
okay it's okay I'm here we're oh my God
you're or any she's not dead she ran
away the [__] and yum your Mom owes me
80 grand when you have it you'll get
your dog back I don't have any money you
can sell your eggs it's not like you're
using them no there has to be another
way what is the square root of 196 14
correct how many hearts does an octopus
have correct what saffron Saturn
Aphrodite Apollo Aries carbon dioxide
the equal sign correct oh my God what
you know this game this is how you're
going to make the money I'm taking you
to the quiz
look learn out of Drive racist oh hi
come on it's going to be fun I'm not
sleeping on the floor I'm not sleeping
on the floor either I sleep on the chair
I don't want to sleep in a sitting
position oh my
God I can't play on live TV in front of
millions of people I'll let you get to
it I know you got to get through hair
and makeup I already went through hair
and makeup well and you missed a spot I
can't do this am I sting yeah you know
what put your arms down you're having a
panic attack doctors prescribe these is
that
cocaine I Stevia do do you ever use
Stevia the sweetener yeah yeah I've got
it in my
pocket win or lose we'll do it
together that is definitely broken I bet
you I could pop it back in my son no I
can't I'm going to throw
[Music]
up how can I ever thank you maybe like a
drink later well I'm married and gay
why' you have to say two
reasons
Thanksgiving is a time for
appreciation it's a time to remember our
many
blessings to celebrate with the ones
that we love the
most and it's time for All Families to
be
[Music]
together no no no no
[Applause]
no let's
see
[Music]
what
is
what are you doing going back to my room
I didn't do nothing yall never do what
are you doing
welcome home what happen here face this
little going away present from the
boys they let you out early you ain't
out of my reach
boy you're being awful hard on yourself
we can be
forgiven what's going on here Ain no
point of keeping it a secret one of our
own shot with his own pistol which we
can't seem to
find I want to stay with you and if
we're going to stay together we have to
go right now don't move get in the
truck turn on the car and
drive well I think I'll hold on to that
this ain't your gun just give it back to
me I will you tell me who it belongs to
you I shot him and until he wasn't
moving no more I no place you can go
somewhere safe I'm going to trust you
you're going to have to trust
me what the hell is going on need that
old place I'll explain everything later
all right I got your back a woman came
into the show said little girl now a
lady working there say she found a
pistol on her before she took off
[Music]
running I just need to know if Russell
stayed here with you tonight in full ass
as far as I know he was
here we got one brother dead I ain't
looking to be
[Music]
another this is
seems like you and I were tied together
by some sort of invisible
role We Fight
Together just do the best you can for
right now you don't worry about the mark
till it
[Music]
comes a somebody help
us
[Music]
this is the end for us Life's a whirl
will we're all caught up in
it gentlemen I've got good news lady
death is alive I didn't know we thought
she was dead sir I sent her on a mission
to terminate Ivan bubalo the cult leader
his regime is quickly gaining the
political and territorial foothold to
cause serious unrest in the
region gentlemen your mission is to
extract lady d and finish what she
started let's get to work go the CIA
can't officially be involved that's
where we come in Yi
safe yeah she's fine what about the girl
she's working for the United
States find
her at any
cost Al there's a tracking device on
you I lost contact with my team I need
help finding them assuming they're still
alive let's go I don't even know how to
use this do
[Music]
this honestly that was pretty easy
thought there'd be more of them
may God bless the state of Aragon I
have is it done no it
[Music]
isn't GTA 5 minutes to the war zone we
must
why Soldier
[Music]
no
go
[Music]
help
start from the
beginning yo bizel click clack it's
showtime is it some type of prank or
something this ain't no prank R boy this
is CRI watch UK live and dirting your
face click clack hey sprinkle if you
wanted to play with a big hard toy then
you should have just asked you know M I
was just joking in it shut up you
[__] leave it yeah serious I
can allow it pting Alexa stop the music
fam sorry fam click
clack we laughing stop
man I'm out here looking for Redemption
bro are you on it or not I'm on it CZ we
going need some more soldiers I'm going
to call my man minute I ain't got time
for your CBBC Ming blood this time you
do something that's going to finally put
us on the map give me everything you got
P 10 PS five PS and even the brown
pennies you want the pennies [__] me how
much long is this going to
take ring ring [__] it's your mommy on
the
phone Reco and came Bang Bang all day
midday man said all day midday I love
that you're a bad man yeah they don't
call me by away for nothing you know
ohow it
man you are beautiful hold
on hello can't you see this he's a
double yellow
light what you not saying what the [__]
man that's nasty can you not do
that I'm going to need some more of your
produ allow it waste man you want
SI who is weo Click CL it's w
and try to lock me up like some cage
animal this ain't 12 Years a Slave czy
this is some
otherhood if your blls don't smell like
they used to can you shut the [__] up
I'm trying to watch goggle
BX countless reports of arson and
vandalism a state of emergency as
violence reached historic levels go
knock him dead and then revive him again
and just keep like an endless loop
you're going to be riding with Jason 15
years on the job you can do a lot worse
there's possible stabbing of one male
party 412 Broadway okay here we go let's
move okay right he kills a cop drops the
car here he puts a body in the front
seat who does
that
oh my God picking up traces of some type
of acceler this was
intentional back up
now back up come on there something
wrong with
it these are messages
[Applause]
bro
we get what we
[Music]
deserve oh nice tuugs thank you wow
sural right yeah
[Music]
yeah wait wait wait where where are we
going
Felix you think you'll go home
honestly home doesn't mean the same for
me as it does for you Felix well why
don't you come home with me come to Sal
[Music]
them I see Felix likes you so
much you're so um
real Oliver I have a complete and utter
horror of ugliness ever since I was very
young I don't know why mean because
you're a terrible
person lots of people get lost in
saltburn this place it's not for
you I can honestly say that these last
few months have been the happiest of my
life anything else I should know about
no no just be yourself I love you it
it's relaxed I
[Music]
promise
coming through I'm here
wait Pebble Brook is threatened into sew
for Mis handling his case what your son
is on line one sit down hey my love
how's your first day going I'm coming
home honey Steiners are not quitters
we're Fighters I'm not a fighter I'm a
daily upper
decker it was him
get I don't even know what that means
you went to undergrad at Barnett
University you were president of your
sority and popular with all the guys
right I mean yeah little look at you my
son is a really good kid but he's a
recluse I would like to hire you to go
back take him under your wing you want
to pay me to go back to
Barnett yeah hly I'm getting pay to go
back to college and you're going to come
with me you know I'm really sorry get
back to your station my AP juice boxes
for everybody we have until homecoming
to get this kid from Zero to Hero well
how are you supposed to we do that this
is paully and I'm olly we're actually
thinking about going to Still Waters you
should come with us we could convince
the girl to come with us I was in the
neighborhood and I just wanted
see get out of here bro why do you want
to help me so much we all deserve a
second chance at a first
impression I want to dedicate this shot
to my boy Elliot one two
[Applause]
Jesus you won't step foot in here again
care to make a wager on that Boo's Caton
if we win Elliot gets Bid And if I win
how about Keys yes the whole car [__]
you're
[Music]
on
I am paying you to help my son get
adjusted to college not ruin his
life just think of me as your little
Jiminy
Cricket I you feel
[Applause]
it Tam mly singer hope your second time
around was
fine give a little Spanky
spank and that son is an important
lesson and
consent
is that that guy Robert again listen
concession stand girl why don't you give
me your
[Music]
number wait you never said where he goes
to school I think he just
works oysters come on he has cats his
eyes are nice he crinkle yeah cuz he's
old I think I really like him as
promised I'm not saying I will sex with
him but I think he would like it why are
we having this conversation he's a
terrible
kisser listen to me call it a night hey
do we want to do
this this is the worst life decision
I've ever
made I had a good time tonight
didn't you
yeah so what was his go-to move the
reverse squatting cowgirl or is cats at
least cute I never saw them
uh-oh why lie about having
cats cuz liking cats makes a guy seem
non-threatening
harmless he's hiding
[Music]
something I'm the monster in your
mind I need to keep someone away from me
you scar me people choose to be
scared can't say I'm surprised to find
lovely ladies like yourselves in here
looking for protection Kelvin you need
to shut that [__] down right
now what is the matter with you you
manipulated
me so he called you a [__] if you want
to get along with a man and not be alone
your whole entire life make
peace well a little
discomfort one of us has to
die I the
[Music]
monster I'm Clarence I'm not a man
without faults I played the cards I was
deal man in spite of your selfish ways
there is a beautiful soul in there
somewhere it's him Jesus of Nazareth I'm
not you can't even buy Power like that
I'm not I want to be like that in 10
[Music]
years I want to be like that
now knowledge is stronger than
believe PL you need Miracles I have a
plan I can see I can
see God sent me to deliver his message
Mah I am your new
Messiah BL a Swain stop
that
your God is a
myth see for yourselves there is no
Messiah parents if you'll be so kind to
walk on
water
damn
[Music]